you don't have to look far in
westminster for a pub and you don't have
to wait long for a sexism scandal so
after a depressingly familiar week of
revelations here what can be done
well anyone hoping for specifics from
either of the main parties today will be
disappointed listen to the business
secretary on shutting bars in parliament
no they shouldn't all be shut i don't
think we should have a kind of uh
excessively puritanical or severe regime
in that regard on the direct employment
of staff by mps it's not my view not my
opinion uh that matters in this and on
all women shortlists i've never been a
fan frankly personally of um quotas and
shortlists so is there a culture problem
i don't think there's a culture of
misogyny i think the problem we have
is that people are working in a really
intense environment
well for labour there were big words but
again little detail what actually needs
to happen behavioral change that we all
have to contribute to uh cultural change
taking responsibility
i understand all these words but but
what's
what specifically
needs to change well
where an individual um is involved in
these sorts of behaviors they need to
take absolute responsibility straight
away
one person who has put forward
suggestions is the common speaker sir
lindsey hoyle worried by the levels of
complaints he wants a review of working
practices in parliament and potential
changes to how mp's staff are employed
i've never been a fan but is a larger
part of the problem staring us in the
face not so much the drinking or late
night working or employment practices
not what politicians do but who they are
out of five uk party leaders and one
cabinet minister interviewed this
morning there was just one woman and for
many that's the big issue not so much
rules but representation
tory party chairman oliver dowden today
vowed to reopen the candidates list and
select more prospective female mps but
there are warnings in the current
climate that's easier said than done
it's been really difficult to get women
to come forward and stand for election
because there is a sense that politics
and public life is not a safe space for
women anymore and we need to do
something about that because we're going
to rule the day if we continue down this
path and women just don't see
the ability to come forward and be
active in politics so another round of
outrage in westminster as yet few signs
of how or when time will really be
called on an issue that's dogged
politics for decades
broadcast sky news in westminster